[Music]
hey guys and that again with your
favorite yoga teacher Nika Karan
so today's workout it's great view if
you're a senior or if you're slightly
folded this workout is perfect for to
improve on your flexibility isn't it we
are going to work on our flexibility
especially flexibility of the hip we are
also going to improve your balance and
bone health so yep it's really gentle
you can start it and I'm sure you will
be able to follow this workout so let's
get on to the mat let's do it you're
going to start sitting comfortably on
the mat you can cross your legs in
whichever way you would like if you feel
like your hips are not comfortable you
can always pull up a blog and sit down
on the block this is fine and bring the
hands on your knees keep your back
straight close your eyes and it scoop it
on our breath for a moment relax your
shoulders and breathe deeply through
your nose
inhale deeply Jan tsk
[Music]
and with time inhale deeply and again at
hello Serena imma be deep breath in
[Music]
and as you exhale out slowly drop your
chin to attach has not rotate your head
in the extra gently slowly okay one more
round
[Music]
straighten up your hat
open your eyes let's just stretch our
hands in front and you're going to warm
up our wrists a little bit a lot of
times are raised on a fitting degree
when you put too much pressure later on
in it we can do it a to warm it up all
right
and release from here bring your right
when you left knee left hand behind
twist to the left
gentle quality sign and to the other
side right hand behind you and wiggle
your right shoulder all right you're
back in the center we'll try to move our
hips gently bring your feet together
grab hold of your feet and see if you
can just we're going to like to little
bit up and down okay
and the little butterfly toes here get
warming up your hip and then release
let's bring a little eggs behind hands
on your mat and we're going to again
warm up the spine with the cat and cow
stretches so just place your palms
underneath your shoulders and knees
underneath your hips keep your pint
spine straight and then gently just
scoop it held on bring your chin towards
your chest and then slowly roll up and
again Archibeque
and then slowly adding Telstra it's
really amazing for your spine
helps you warm it up stretch it up one
time arch and we get straight and second
you're fine from here let's bring the
left leg to the back and stay here in
the middle okay Brenda to collapse
keep your chest straight and at your
first balancing pose here
keep your toes pointing down and look
forward reading deeply through your name
when you hear you'll add another element
to it we'll add your right hand all the
way forward and to challenge your vote
in your balance a little bit more just
look straight you'll see your full core
working here breathe and then slowly
exhale Aziz let's repeat on the other
side bring the right leg straight up so
it's gonna be pointing down chest is
nice and open look straight and breathe
deeply through your nose
one more remember to collapse and check
here nice and straight and let's add
your left hand balance trying to stay in
the middle
lengthening through your leg so you can
balance
okay as you exhale slowly from here
we're going to talk you toes and gently
roll you'll find all whipping to our
first down the jaw down it is great to
stretch your whole body you can walk in
one place just to stretch your
hamstrings and make sure that you're
lengthening through your spine you can
keep your knees band if you have strings
a little bit tight just land him through
your back and sit still and you know
down with that for a moment trying to
bring your hips as high as you can just
breathe deeply focus on your breath
[Music]
one would be breasts and gently exhale
with your next inhale we're going to
roll body bowl with gel because with
your plank pose again shoulders above
your wrists your core is engage and
there's no you just drop your knees down
you're going to go jumping into your
Cobra per album screw the pooch as and
any chance you can just go a little bit
higher you have to go all the way up
remember to roll your shoulders to the
back lift your chest up again
strengthening your back and from here
lift a little bit high friend you knee
and release into your child escapes
forehead down lengthen your spine take a
deep breath in relax and down slowly
with an inch and lift your head up so
all the time go into your downward
good inhale and one within roll all the
way forward into your plank pose nice
triple here get inhale exhale drop your
knees down and slowly lower good gender
with inhaling this depth you know far
you can go without straining your back
ring maybe you can go a little bit
higher
Brady up old and roll your shoulders to
the back and then again they're down and
slowly go down into your childhood
stretch you're fine
one with deep breath in and lift into
your down with that let's repeat one
last time down the down inhale and then
Jen you roll all the way forward yeah
strong core here drop your knees down
and very good
[Music]
we inhale lift up see how far you can go
just to strengthen the lower back
relieve the shoulder and again all the
way to your child another deep breath in
exhale oh and from here we're going to
lift up again into your downward dog you
know they say that Donald Duck a day
will keep the doctor away it's a really
great pose to stretch your whole body
and from here we're going to drop your
right knee down I'm going to do a little
bit of a easy version for sometimes auto
with the hip I'm going to bring the left
let's go and all right and then slowly
lift up ground your right foot the hands
are going all the way for your one make
sure you're squaring the hips forward if
it doesn't feel too good on your ankle
you can always point your foot forward
into high lunge just see how it's feel
hands up nice easy warrior one shoulders
rolling down breathe in balance take a
deep breath in and exhale ah as we
inhale stretch it all the way up and
we're going to go into warrior two hands
to the side really left me right above
your ankle and breathe in your warrior
two
deep breaths here show the three left
inhale stretch as you exhale bring your
left hand all the way forward and down
right hand reaching up see how far you
can go maybe you can go all the way down
to the ground if not stay here okay look
up to with your right palm in a nice
triangle pose shoulders dropping chest
through stretching the last leg inhale
reaching all the way up gently close to
the flag open up your chest and as you
exhale go down into the side angle left
elbow on your knee right hand above your
head opening the chest stretching the
whole right side of your body maybe this
is your palm up straight that's fine and
as you exhale gently release drop your
knees down and try to slam your legs all
the way to the back good and again
gentle is going to you to surrender
inhale Cobra oh baby proofer see how far
you can go Hakeem you chose and going to
your down
because we breath in here and hello
let's repeat on the other side let's
bring the left knee down right like I'm
all the way forward lift your left hand
up ground the left foot hands up for
your way back to shoulder sure your body
is not handing we'd bring the hip inhale
lift all the way up and as you exhale go
to warrior two good right knee right
above the ankle shoulders straight and
relaxed in healthy P and exhale up
straighten your right knee inhale lift
up as you exhale right thumb goes all
the way forward and down triangle if you
want to bring your feet a little bit
closer here look go with your left palm
keeping the chest open one would you
present exhale up with your next inhale
gently lift all the way up and fill to
the back you can do with your right palm
gentle stretch inhale look your exhale
bend your right knee
let's go into your side angle right
elbow on your left hand above your hat
looking to the side stretching the whole
left side of your body this side
keep breathing lengthen through the
spine slowly let's release your left
hand down left knee down and send your
right leg to the back inhale lift up
into your down with ya and again a
gentle stretch here lengthening through
the spine and calf relaxing your
shoulders bring it down away from your
ears
inhale one with time and as you exhale
we're going to jump you walk forward to
the middle of your mat and just fold
your hands you can keep your knees
slightly Bend and just sway from side to
side and then lengthen into the spine
relaxing your lower back from here
slowly head bring your hands up building
the strength of your legs bringing the
bone density easy chair pose as you
inhale let's lift all the way up bring
your palms to your chest from here we're
going to go to tree pose so just bring
your pumps on your hips and bring your
right foot on top of your left paw if
you can you can bring it even higher on
top of your in a tie and then bring your
palm for your chest just see whatever
works
working on the strength of your cup of
your ankles to 3dc relax your shoulders
try not to close your eyes it will be
harder to balance
inhale bc exhale ah
and then slowly try to reach your hand
all get above your head
continue balancing bang in the middle
relaxing your shoulders take one with
the breath in and then slowly release
your hands and bring your palm so if you
need try to bring any to your chest and
again it might be a little wobbly at
first but it will definitely improve as
you continue practicing this balancing
poses can be deeply shoulders are
relaxing and then slowly release all the
way down all right dad I'm gonna sit on
the other side right leg straight left
foot goes on top of your inner time I've
got to comfortable you could come find
your balance you can lower your leg all
the way down and support shoulders
relaxed straight spine like in your
tummy a little bit and stay here breathe
not a - come on as you inhale that
stretch your hands all the way up
relaxing the shoulders can then turn
into the spine look at thing in your bra
two more
[Music]
one and as the exhale drop your pump
down inhale bring any to your chest you
can lower your shoulders long fine try
to balance here get one McGee breath in
exhale out
then slowly sit okay relax your ankles
from here with inhale you're going to go
up one more time lift your hands up and
let's lift up on your toes and again to
improve the flexibility of your ankles
you're going to go down okay and again
lift up just on your toes exhale slowly
down and again inhale lift up and exhale
down inhale up exhale down one more time
inhale and as you exhale it straight to
go all the way down I really love the
again slowly all the way down dropping
the knees on the mat let's sit back
bringing the right foot towards the
chest grab with your foot and right come
goes on your knees okay are you going to
go into a rocker baby pose all right
this again to improve flexibility and
mobility of your hip okay as we get a
little bit older usually that's becoming
quite a problem matching a tight area in
our body so that's an easy way to just
open it up and loosen it up a little bit
okay yeah and slowly release in from
here just twist to the right look over
your right shoulder gently open your
chest sit up straight
trying to lean back too much take a deep
breath in
some access then slowly back forward ice
try to just go forward a little bit
again see how far you can go
you don't have to touch your forehead to
your knee okay don't worry
it can even have in a little bit bend
that's why that's stretching the
hamstrings here as the in here let's mix
all the way up let's repeat on the other
side turn right leg goes straight you're
going to grab hold of your right of your
left foot
sorry and again just rock sit straight
opening the hip a little bit here and
this is how you rock the baby to see
slowly and then release your foot down
inhale bring your hands up as you exhale
twist over to the left side sit straight
twisting your lower back also feeling
that nice twist in your abdominals take
a deep breath in exhale oh and then
again back to the center inhale as you
exhale then pull it feel free to keep it
nice then when we're here and all the
whole wood bends you don't want to push
it work with your building and see how
far you can go inhale on the same up as
the egg-cam
cherlene and let's bring our feet
together again for that butterfly pose
when we are just going to open the hips
a little bit here
[Music]
keep breathing do you think make sure
you sitting straight be on top and
inhale bring your head up and on the
exhale try to gently bend or again no
pushing or pulling work with your body
keep breathing
one more next
put your neck inhale lift your head up
let's extend our legs full and we're
going to gently roll all the way into
our back
let's bring both knees to chest and
squeeze your knees tighten it to your
child with inhale we're going to slowly
lift your head up and try to bring it
towards the knees here this is a great
pose to improve your digestive health
breathing speeding in usage have one
more time inhale toes pointing down
exhale out bring your head down very
good from here drop your hands down
stretch your leg all the way up toes
pointing towards your face if you want
you can do this food against the wall
it's really great to improve your blood
circulation so you can just hold it
against the wall or the way we are doing
it here okay
hold it straight up exhale out
one two time inhale and exhale out all
right and from here you can lower your
left leg down bring your right knee to
chest inhale all the time bring your
forehead to to knee breathe release your
left foot points straight inhale as you
exhale release your head down and let's
just bring your right leg all the way to
the left side and your right hand
pointing to the right let's go with your
right palm
get a nice gentle twist on your thigh
one more inhale gently exhale oh let's
release back to the center this is your
right leg down left leg comes all the
way to your chest
we know tight inhale lift your head all
the way up forehead foot to knee so
right toes pointing down inhale exhale
oh and then gently release your head
down bring your right knee all the way
left
III all the way to the right left hand
reaching out make sure your left
shoulder stays on stays on the ground
you want to go to deepen the twist I
just want to relax your spine inhale
let's lift all the way up in the center
and as you exhale release both legs into
everybody's favorite pose so fellow and
found facing upwards leg apart if this
is uncomfortable for you you can always
bring your knees to your chest and see
here or you can bring your feet down on
the ground within you Spence
and whatever is more comfortable and
just keep your eyes closed
bring attention to your breath slowly
relaxing your whole body relaxing your
head and shoulders is fine and your
child relaxed and your both legs
[Music]
the whole body is relaxed
pick one with the breath in chanting
hello
[Music]
and Jen you bring the awareness back to
you body will go your toes and fingers
again bring your knees to your chest
give it a nice squeeze maybe rock from
side to side and then slowly come until
one side and Jen if you lift all the way
up into this you get so I hope you enjoy
this pretty simple routine guys you can
do it every day to increase your
flexibility and your mobility so yeah do
let us know in the comments below how it
goes let us know what other yoga
sequence would you like to learn from
Mika in the comments below and you can
also check out more yoga videos right at
the end of this video and also in the
description box so be sure to subscribe
to my youtube channel and follow me cow
on the social media pages all the best